la cuma ne sais quoi de cannes a manqué
le tamarin alors le stamm arrière de
madagascar vous y voyez vous imaginez
son voyage aujourd'hui on a voulu
partager avec les enfants
le métissage et italie une exposition
qui se tient au lazaret de la grande
chaloupe
quand on fait découvrir aux enfants l
usage des plantes des usages
alimentaires des usages domestiques mais
aussi culturel pourquoi les gens à l'île
de la réunion utilise des plantes par
exemple pourquoi les mâles baromètre des
guirlandes de feuilles de monde à leur
fenêtre à leur corde qu'est ce que cela
signifie donc tout ça est expliqué on
invite les enfants donc à redécouvrir
découvrir et redécouvrir les fruits pays
avec un croisement un clin d'oeil de
l'histoire
et
de là nous avons des fiches pédagogiques
avec l'image dont qui s'y retrouvent et
qu'ils voulaient remettre aussi dans le
contexte
vous avez déjà vu ça au marché forain et
là ça revient et il faut pas hésiter
parler aussi des goûts des saveurs
parce que certains c'est à oui ça m'a
piqué on peut donc ça c'était le tamarin
voilà il faut jouer avec tous les sens
pour les invités car oui